Tengámoslo claro el mundo nunca antes
había estado mejor gracias en gran
medida a la globalización cada vez hay
menos guerras, la pobreza se está
reduciendo con fuerza y todos los
parámetros referentes a la calidad de
vida mejoran. No claro de forma uniforme
pero sí bajo una perspectiva global .Sin
embargo, contra todo pronóstico en el
mejor momento de la humanidad
muchos países occidentales han decidido
rebelarse y apagar la antorcha de la
apertura y el entendimiento entre los
pueblos.
En Europa, por ejemplo, los partidos de
extrema derecha están sembrando el
desconcierto: Le Pen en Francia o Hoffer
en Austria son buenos ejemplos de una
ola que también recorre Finlandia,
Dinamarca, Alemania o Hungría, entre
otros. Y que incluso ha sido responsable
en gran medida de la victoria del BREXIT
en Reino Unido.
Un movimiento que explota el miedo a lo
diferente aun cuando vivimos en
sociedades que cada vez son más seguras.
De hecho como podemos ver un británico
de hoy en día tiene 135 veces
menos posibilidades de morir asesinado
que su homólogo en la Edad Media. Pero esta
corriente todos lo sabéis no es
monopolio de Europa.
Donald Trump ha ganado las elecciones en
Estados Unidos o con un discurso
claramente contrario a la globalización
y la inmigración.
A estas alturas del partido la mejor
pregunta que nos podemos hacer y si no
queda acaso algún país desarrollado
que siga apostando por la apertura.
Pues sí, los hay y hoy vamos a hablar de uno
de sus abanderados.
En todo el año 2016, Canadá
habrá admitido a más de 300.000 nuevos
inmigrantes, cerca del 1 por ciento de su
población. Una proporción mayor que la de
prácticamente cualquier otro país
grande y desarrollado. Y ojo, no es una
apuesta nueva lleva en vigor más de dos
décadas.
El resultado es que hoy uno de cada
cinco canadienses ha nacido en el
extranjero,
un porcentaje que casi duplica al de
Estados Unidos o España, por ejemplo.
Y la verdad sea dicha, es que esto no ha
conllevado ninguna desgracia nacional.
Todo lo contrario. Y los canadienses son
los primeros en saberlo. Según un
estudio del prestigioso Environics
Institute la inmensa mayoría de los
ciudadanos,
prácticamente ocho de cada diez,
consideran que la inmigración es buena
para la economía y que representa la
mejor forma de enfrentarse a problemas
tan importantes como el envejecimiento
demográfico.
Sí lo pensáis, tiene bastante sentido.
El factor trabajo es el recurso
productivo más importante así que por
qué impedir que crezca. En el marco de
una economía dinámica, qué tiene de
malo que haya más personas dispuestas a
trabajar, a montar empresas o a formarse
o especializarse.
De hecho es algo bueno.
En octubre de 2015, Justin Trudeau se convirtió
en primer ministro al derrotar contra
todo pronóstico al conservador Stephen
Harper quien había ocupado el poder
durante prácticamente diez años. Desde
entonces la agenda política está
dominada por el empeño del gobierno en
profundizar en políticas aperturistas y
pro globalización. Y el propio Trudeau
un hombre de izquierdas se ha convertido
en todo un paladín en favor del libre
comercio y la movilidad de las personas.
En su primer año de mandato ha firmado
el acuerdo de libre comercio con la
Unión Europea y ha confirmado la
adhesión de Canadá al TPP. En un solo
año
Canadá ha forjado relaciones de libre
comercio con cerca del 60% de
la economía mundial.
Y ojo, Trudeau ahora quiere hacer algo similar
con China.
"Decidimos iniciar discusiones
exploratorias con vistas a un acuerdo de
libre comercio entre Canadá y China".
Y respecto a la inmigración, el gobierno
canadiense está en la misma línea.
Incluso se ha fijado como meta aumentar
el número de inmigrantes que recibe
cada año en un 50%.
" Canadá necesita más inmigrantes,
necesitamos la llegada de sangre más
joven para mantener nuestras economías
en marcha".
Dada esta vocación no puede
sorprendernos que Canadá está siendo uno
de los países más comprometidos a la
hora de facilitar la llegada de los
refugiados sirios. Desde que Trudeau es
primer ministro Canadá ha dado acogida más
de 33.000 sirios incluso durante su
primer mes de gobierno,
el propio primer ministro se acercó al
aeropuerto de Toronto para darles la
bienvenida al país.
Qué diferencia con lo que está
ocurriendo en España.
¡Ojo! En Canadá
la inmigración no es libre está
regulada más de lo que a los miembros
de este canal nos gustaría pero la
cuestión es que no se trata ni mucho
menos de que no exista ningún requisito
administrativo, sino de que no
consideremos nunca como delincuentes a
quienes quieren venir a trabajar a
emprender y a forjar una vida en
nuestros países. Y ése es precisamente
el éxito Canadá, un país que se jacta
de buscar ciudadanos y no inmigrantes
temporales. Desde 1967 existe un sistema
de puntos que tiene en cuenta la
cualificación, la experiencia, las
habilidades profesionales o la capacidad
para hablar inglés o francés.
De la misma forma que también se da
preferencia a los profesionales
demandados por las empresas.
" La visa de Canadá con México será eliminada,
terminada, finita, caput".
La tendencia de
los últimos años pasa por agilizar y
facilitar estos procedimientos pero la
cuestión más importante no es ésta,
sino el reconocimiento social y el marco
de integración a los inmigrantes que
existe. La propia carta de derechos y
libertades de Canadá, ¡ojo! reconoce el
concepto de patrimonio multicultural. En
este país existen sólidas políticas
para favorecer la integración que por
cierto pasan casi siempre por animar
a los recién llegados a no perder su
identidad cultural y a considerar la
diversidad como un factor enriquecedor.
Por ejemplo, en los propios colegios
públicos es fácil encontrar clases
impartidas en español o en ucraniano.
Y desde luego los resultados avalan estas
políticas: en la última década
Canadá ha crecido más que Estados
Unidos, Alemania o Reino Unido; y ha
consolidado un nivel de vida muy
elevado.
Ahora ya podemos entender por qué la
web canadiense de inmigración se
colapsó a las pocas horas de conocerse
que Trump sería el nuevo presidente de
los Estados Unidos o que The Economist le
dediqué portadas como ésta.
Incluso nuestros amigos de
Expatistán cuentan cómo el tráfico
desde Estados Unidos se ha disparado los
últimos días.
Desde luego, Candá dista mucho de ser
un modelo perfecto pero frente a las
corrientes nacionalistas y populistas
este país muestra como la alternativa a
la libertad es deseable. Porque amigos
la clave está en hacer mejor las cosas,
no en encerrarse al mundo tal y como
defienden políticos como Donald Trump.
Bueno ahora te toca a ti, ¿crees que la
inmigración entre a tantos problemas
como afirman algunos? ¿no prefieres acaso
vivir en sociedades abiertas y diversas
como la canadiense?
Espero vuestras respuestas y desde luego
si aún no os habéis suscrito a
VisualPolitik podéis hacerlo ahora pulsando
en este botón. Y también os invito a
darle a like
si os ha gustado esta alternativa a las
políticas de Donald Trump. ¡Un saludo y
hasta la próxima amigos!